we were tremendously comforted by the uh
thought that they were apprehended and
eliminated and
um that everybody in the Western World
can effectively sleep safely in their
beds tonight therefore the Israeli Army
has done tremendous uh kindness to the
World by taking out two people who could
theoretically go and bomb uh New York
London Paris Tel Aviv and kill many more
innocent uh civilians I think this week
as well you had the opportunity to
listen to the heartbeats
of the recipient of Lucy's heart
I mean that must be an absolutely
extraordinary moment well I didn't
actually listen to it because I'm very
squeamish but my daughters did and they
found it very emotional
um what I found very emotional was that
the lady who received the heart uh was
referred to as little but when she met
me she said by the way my name is
actually Rina little
and I found that very powerful and the
mother of the boy who received the liver
told me my name is Maya so we had a Maya
and we had arena in the room and there
we were with Lucy's organs living in
these people's bodies it was just crazy
and
I don't know a complete mixture of
emotions
um when we last met it was during the
shiver period the morning period for
your wife and daughter it's in I think
you described um your feelings at the
time to me as though you were running on
some adrenaline because you had this
um extraordinary sort of a collection of
people who'd come to support you and to
mourn with you
there's a number of weeks on now how are
you feeling now because I know you were
worried that you might suddenly have a
quite a cruel and harsh calm down
I I've had a number of ups and downs as
you can imagine and I've been in tears
and I've been uh you know had moments of
of not being in tears
um my psychologist said to me there are
five levels of grief and the top level
is finding meaning
um so she said it looks like you've
jumped to the top level and missed the
other four but I imagine I said to her I
imagine I will go through the other four
in random orders over the next few
months and years and I think that's
what's happening
and how about the children how are they
um they um when they were their friends
and when they're busy are able to keep
themselves together but when they are
alone and they're tired and hungry as
you imagine
um then the fact that it's now four of
us it was seven is very poignant in this
house